what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I was going down the rabbit hole of
like characters I started out with
trying to find like some weird and wacky
story involving Thor and then I found a
story where he died and that story was
where he died alongside everybody else
the problem is that it that his death
along with the deaths of all the other
superheroes is referenced but not
actually seen and I was going through
and trying to find the point where you
actually saw it happen which of course I
didn't find but I basically ran on this
story King Hyperion that comes from the
exiles now we've only ever really talked
about the exiles previously kind of like
in passing but never really talked about
him in any measure of death the exiles
were actually a team were actually a
comic that was created by Marvel were
created by Judd Winick on behalf of
Marvel and the goal was to basically
take the concept of a what-if story
which is to say what if things happen
differently like what if spider-man kept
the Venom symbiote instead of getting
rid of it and then basically turn that
into an ongoing series the overall gist
of the Exiles
is that they are basically a team of
individuals who serve the purpose of
traveling around the multiverse and
fixing things but the whole role
portrayed by the exiles eventually went
away this was basically a team where the
story lasted for about a hundred and
eight issues I think it was least in the
first volume eventually Chris Claremont
came on war with issue number ninety
lasted 18 issues that got cancelled
Marvel try to bring it back a couple
more times but it never really lasted
anything more than 18 issues the second
run called new exiles lasted 18 issues
the third attempt to launch it lasted
six and then Marvel just took the
concept of exploring the multiverse and
just threw it in a different stories all
that was in the midst of the huge
reshuffling going on in Marvel in the
mid-2000s but the idea is that the X
Isles server the behest of a guy called
time broker and time broker basically
has this artifact called the talus and
the talus basically tells the exiles
what they're supposed to be doing the
idea here is that in addition to the
exiles do as a team called Weapon X this
name was simply given to this other
version of the exiles because the Weapon
X title is so popular among both comic
readers and non comic readers but the
idea is that where the exiles are
basically good guys trying to solve
problems Weapon X is really more of like
a black ops team they're basically
assigned to go in and fix multiversal
problems by going through and killing
people in this instance as it stands
right now what this does is it actually
picks up with similar care
albeit playing different roles of course
we have Colossus
we have vision but one of the characters
or I guess a couple of the characters
who were a little more unique here than
others are Carol Danvers and spider-man
Carol Danvers is a lot more ruthless
here she's a lot more cruel she's a lot
more hardcore in the main Marvel Comics
Carol Danvers was really more of a
character where she was just trying to
get people to care about her she was
just like hey look I'm a superhero too
and nobody ever really seemed to care
that much but with Peter Parker this is
interesting and this is what we started
to get into like the what-if concept in
this instance it's what if Peter Parker
had been bonded to the carnage symbiote
and so in this story Peter Parker's
basically Cletus Kasady he's insane but
the overall goal is the idea that they
are basically here to kill Bruce Banner
and that's kind of the ruthless nature
of it is because there's not some great
big huge epic fight between Bruce Banner
Hulk and like the Weapon X team instead
he just dies Carol Danvers just kills
him right off the bat and that's really
it now of course what this does is it
also leads to the Weapon X team
basically being teleported to the new
universe and for the most part it was
this idea that like the exiles there
were people who were brought together
from different universes but they were
basically told if you fix enough of
these problems you'll be allowed to go
home they're just kind of shanghaied
into it but what this also does is it
brings back into play the character of
Hyperion because of the fact that
Hyperion was introduced as Marvel's
version of Superman his character kind
of waxed and waned over the years but
the idea of the exiles was to test the
waters it was basically a newer
iteration of the anthology College where
you would have five different stories in
a singular comic this served the same
purpose instead of being a whole bunch
of stories on one comic it would be one
story but it would bring in a character
that fans liked at one point didn't
really seem to like anymore and mom
would basically reintroduce them and say
hey would you be interested in seeing
this character more often but in this
new universe where they get teleported
to essentially what had happened is H
Xavier's dream of a peaceful coexistence
between humans and utens completely and
totally failed basically humans ended up
launching an attack simultaneously
against the x-men under Charles Xavier
and all the superheroes across earth the
result is that all but 10 mutants are
basically eradicated and the earth
superheroes the Avengers are dead that
all happens off panel we never actually
see that take place but what had
happened is magneto had grabbed a
full of mutants brought them aboard
asteroid in basically his base of
operations that's literally an asteroid
orbiting Earth and then said okay fine
if humanity wants to play this game then
we'll annihilate them all now of course
the role of Weapon X being here is to
simply eliminate the last ten mutants
but one of them is basically revealed to
be Kitty Pryde who was essentially
spying on Hyperion and Carol Danvers
touchin naughty bits is really what is
really what was going on with him but
remember for Kitty Pryde hiding out and
basically staying you know staying
hidden from the whole series of events
basically means that she doesn't know
the state of a lot of the mutants who
were out there and so when she sees
Colossus her initial thought is that
this is the Colossus that I know she's
now forced Peter immediately just clears
that out and says no no no I'm not the
Colossus that you know but if he gives
the process of setting the stage for the
destruction of all of humanity because
the goal of a magneto is to basically
grab asteroid M to simply sim asteroid M
crashing into Earth and then to take
their ship and just sail off to another
planet and live on that one but we also
end up finding out the last remaining
mutants are aboard asteroid M so
basically Iceman Forge Quicksilver
mystique different things like that and
so what is up happening here is that
initially there's some descent in the
sense that Hyperion basically says hey
look yeah we've been sent here to kill
these two mutants but like time broker
won't know what's going on until the ten
mutants are dead and then we'll just be
sent to another universe so why kill
them why not just like stay here and
conquer this world it turns into his
attempt to conquer earth now what this
does is it creates a rift among the team
vision is the first one to go
because vision operates strictly
according to logic and his argument is
we were sent here for a mission we
should complete that mission then we'll
continue on and eventually we'll get our
just rewards once this is all said and
done but in the face of that the other
superheroes basically say yeah Peter
Parker is expected to serve 67
consecutive life sentences for the
people that he killed why not just live
on another earth that they can basically
control this leads directly into
humanity learning magneto sitting in
asteroid and the earth he's basically
gonna obliterate it off but this is what
we see like the full power really like a
strong indication of the power that
Hyperion has he's not human
he's not a normal human being he's an
alien which means he functions
completely separate from anybody else
out there
and so we're normal superheroes are
against the government's used to
with like Incredible Hulk used to
dealing with or those kind of guys
they're not used to dealing with
Hyperion he shows up and obliterates
those sentinels no muss no fuss there's
no questions asked here but also notice
how cruel and how disconnected he is now
he'll get a lot worse by the time this
story comes to an end but at the moment
he has no real regard for Carol Danvers
I mean she's trying to deal with these
signals as best she can and his idea is
we'll basically destroy the central
processor for the sentinels they'll
simply all just shut down the ones who
are attacking you will be destroyed but
maybe you'll die in the process maybe
you'll live I don't know it's not my
concern and that's not my problem now of
course what we also end up learning is
that some of the other mutants who are
basically not there among Magneto have
taken up refuge alongside storm and is
basically storms own personal city and
the ideas of the cities basically
protected by the various electrical
storms different things like that the
she conjures and keeps running 24 hours
a day now when it comes to storms powers
we've seen these fluctuate over the
years and so there's a little bit of
stretching with regards to credulity in
this story because the idea is that
we're basically being asked to believe
that storm can keep these powers going
24 hours a day but we know that just
like anybody else that has to basically
channel their energies to use their
powers eventually she'll wear down and
eventually she'll get tired and just
sort of pass out but the other thing is
that this has happened almost
immediately the formation of this city
is basically in response to the conflict
that's been going on between humans and
mutants for quite some time but it's
only really reached this fever pitch
presumably within the last like week or
so so it's not like she's been doing
this non-stop for like months and months
and months and months but there is gonna
come a point when her power is going to
begin to run down and so in order to
just simply avoid having to answer that
question in the first place
Judd Winick and company actually jump
into this pretty intelligently where
they basically take what would what
would normally be this tail end of her
powers and snip it off and bring this
whole thing coming to bear and so of
course
Hyperion pops up having killed the
President of the United States and this
meets with the arrival of magneto and
company now of course magneto and these
guys are here just because of the fact
that they view that there are those who
fought alongside him and there are those
who fought against him those who chose
to side against him will basically exist
as servants and so the idea here is that
he comes face to face with Hyperion
himself but what this does is
brings into sharp relief the idea that
Hyperion begins falling down the path to
becoming a bad guy now what this also
does is it brings in a character named
Vanisher now the Vanisher was never
really an important character in the
realm of Marvel he was one of those
attempts by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby back
in the 1960s when they first started
writing the x-men he was an attempt by
them to basically introduce these
villains who were really more like
comedic or they were softer villains as
opposed to like the hardcore villains
that we would see and like the Claremont
era going forward from the 70s all the
way up to the modern day and Marvel but
what ended up happening with Vanisher is
who is basically a guy who could
teleport himself around his powers were
expanded over the years and he could
teleport other people but originally he
could only teleport himself and the idea
was that he was just committing crimes
going in events stealing money and that
was really about it in this instance his
character graduated to a higher level of
prominence who eventually became a part
of a group called factor 3 under roy
thomas factor 3 was one of these
old-school x-men teams that existed to
basically try to control the world he
had like mastermind and a handful of
others you know blob and different
things like that of course this also
brings Hyperion into direct conflict
with Magneto where he basically orders
magneto to stop the asteroid now of
course magneto says no any response
Hyperion destroys mystique not only that
he grabs magneto flies him into space
and kills him and so again this is
ruthless this is pretty brutal I mean
he's just like tearing these guys limb
from limb the other half of this is that
storm and gambit are basically two
characters who are missing their other
house in the sense that in gambits own
reality the storm had died in this
universe
gambit had died as it was basically a
chance these characters to just kind of
reconcile and live their lives together
the issue is that it's extremely
short-lived because with this asteroid
coming you know flying towards Earth
what is up happening is Hyperion and
rogue basically work together now of
course this involves Rove touching
Hyperion which of course confirms the
fact that she can absorb a portion of
his power just like anybody else and the
two of them essentially take off into
space in an effort to try to destroy
this asteroid now again this is where
Hyperion gets hardcore because in
attempting to destroy this asteroid it
of course starts breaking into pieces
well in response to this he somebody
says this asteroid can't be stopped it's
just way too big and so he allows rogue
to be totally
rated in the asteroids path the asteroid
crash lands onto earth and it's an
extinction level event every single
human being on earth gets completely
eradicated at this point it's like okay
well then let's just move on the problem
with this is that like Colossus has has
grown close to this universes version of
Kitty Pryde and so in response to this
Hyperion shows up and kills them both
somebody just eradicate to the both of
them at that point it's turning his
sights on to everybody else and so this
turns into a veritable bloodbath Ford is
killed Quicksilver is killed all these
members are just totally eradicated the
only ones left are those who are
faithful to Hyperion whether they're
faithful through fear or whether they're
faithful to the fact that they actually
believe what it is that he's doing is
irrelevant at the end of the day they
side with him and so of course this
leads to I guess spider-carnage
basically going through killing Vanisher
elites to gambit and storm trying to
take off as best they can but it also
brings us a couple versions of other
characters another version of The
Incredible Hulk and a version of
Firestar firestore not really being
important here but the idea is that with
all these individuals having been killed
all that's really left is just
Hyperion's team The Incredible Hulk
Firestar Carol Danvers and
spider-carnage and their idea so we just
move into another universe to go to
another reality to simply say if this is
how things are gonna be then all we have
to do is wait until we find a worth a
world worth conquering and when we do
we'll just take it over and so what this
does is this segues into the next story
a blink in time for Hyperion moves to a
new reality and then actually kills all
that universes superheroes it's crazy
there's one point where he actually
kills Galactus which is completely
bonkers one of the craziest things I've
ever seen but anyway guys I thought it'd
be kind of a cool story to cover here I
thought it'd be pretty interesting
forget you guys might dig it if you guys
are new here to come this explain and
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the raw core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you